[Music]
you are known as the arm collector that
is your
one of your nicknames is the arm
collector what do you mean you're the
arm collector what does it mean well so
far i've had eight fights including my
amateur and uh professional and i've won
all them the first round with an arm bar
and uh an arm bar yeah so like if you
give me your arm okay
all right okay you don't break the arm
you just just located you don't oh
you're gonna wait but wait a minute
before we do anything he said i'm not
gonna break it i'm just going to
dislocate it i'm not really going to do
it right now oh oh thank you
i just want to be really clear that we
have this for insurance purposes you're
this is you dislocate someone's arm no
you push the joint at this point but you
pull it in between your legs and that
that points like on the hips and you
just lean your your back further than
the elbow goes and then um hopefully the
person gives up but if not you just you
keep going and then sometimes it goes
out
but it goes back in it's like it's it's
a wax on wax off process
what do you mean it goes back in
you'd say that if you ripped my arm
completely off
oh it just goes back on a little glue
so you'd get my you pull the arm between
the legs
and then
that would distract me and then bam
back and you dislocated we actually have
uh
uh we have footage i think if you uh
isn't this do we have footage of this
let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right okay
make it stop make it stop
make it
yeah stop my job
it's okay i didn't like her that much
but the idea is that she has to tag out
and when they start to feel their arm i
mean it was
being dislocated that's when they really
quickly say i think i'm time to sell
furniture you know
it's time for another job yeah it's a
weird feeling all right well uh the two
episode special all access ronda rousey
is currently airing on showtime and the
strikeforce women's bantamweight
championship airs saturday august 18th
at 10 p.m on showtime so cool to meet
you thanks a lot you got to come back
some time we got to really fight yeah
yeah
seriously i'm crazy i would do it
my game